If you’ve ever thought to yourself that
your family’s Christmas traditions were
a bit, well… weird, then you’re not alone!
There are some incredibly strange legends
and customs surrounding Christmas time, and
what you do on Christmas day can be vastly
different, depending on where you live.
Here are seven of the strangest Christmas
traditions from around the world.
Iceland has its fair share of strange Christmas
legends, from child-eating cats to Grýla
the troll, but one in particular, the Yule
Lads, holds a place in every Icelandic child’s
heart.
In the past, they were seen as the mischievous
sons of mountain trolls, harassing farmers
and the general population.
But over time, the Yule Lads became much more
benevolent, in the same way Santa Claus is
portrayed today, as a magical, stocking-filling,
bringer of joy.
On the night before December 12th children
all over Iceland would put one of their shoes
out on the windowsill, then head to bed with
a smile on their faces…or a worried frown
if they’d misbehaved.
The thirteen Yule Lads would then come down
one by one on the nights leading up to Christmas
Eve.
Depending on whether the children had been
good or bad, the Yule Lads would leave sweets
and presents, or rotten potatoes in their
shoes.
While potato-ey shoes were definitely a real
concern for some kids, the Icelandic Folk
Customs branch had to step in and discourage
parents, from giving out such extravagant
gifts, as the Yule Lads were seen to be favouring
some kids far more than others.
The awareness campaign advised parents, through
media and kindergartens, hoping to reduce
the festive gap between rich and poor families.
The festive spirit of the Yule Lads remains
well and strong today, perhaps because, today,
they more closely resemble Santa Clause, than
the more sullen image of morose mountain trolls
that their ancestors from the 1700s possessed.
Every year in the Cuban town of Remedios,
a transformation takes place.
In the run up to Christmas, the town splits
in two, and the preparation for the Parrandas
festival begins.
There is a longstanding tradition of competition
between two neighbourhoods in the town; San
Salvador, represented by a rooster, and El
Carmen, represented by a Hawk.
These two sides of the town prepare all year
to battle it out for the title of… best
Christmas festival.
This isn’t your usual friendly competition
between you and your neighbour to see who
has the most Christmas lights, this is an
all-out battle extravaganza that goes back
centuries.
Not only do the residents meticulously decorate
their houses in the themes and colours of
their district, but each hosts their own fireworks
show and float to be presented in the main
display.
Magnificent costumes and dancing in the streets
to a wide orchestra of music, accompanies
the festivities.
You would think you’re at “Carnival,”
except there are Christmas decorations everywhere
instead of Samba dancers.
The festival finds its roots in the 18th century
when the priest in the Grand Cathedral of
Remedios sent out children to gather people
for Christmas mass.
The children would have pots, pans and spoons,
and would run around the town making noise
and singing songs to attract people and lead
them to the mass.
Over time this developed into the fantastically
extravagant street party that we see today.
While this isn’t necessarily a “strange”
tradition, it’s one of unusual intensity,
even when compared to hotspots of Christmas
festivities around Britain and the United
states.
The festivities are so extravagant and infectious
that nearby Cuban towns host their own versions
with their own competing districts every year.
I’m sure you’ve had Christmas carollers
knocking on your door and singing songs to
you before… but what about Mummers?
This bizarre tradition actually has a few
forms across most of Europe, but in Latvia,
it is particularly well-established and accepted
as a local custom.
Latvian “mumming,” done by “mummers”
is a bit like the traditional Christmas carollers,
but there’s a twist.
Mummers dress up as all kinds of creatures
from wolves, to goats, fortune tellers, and
bears, and other amazingly surreal costumes.
They are usually warmly welcomed into homes
as they are believed to drive away evil spirits
with their costumes, dancing, and singing.
These days, it’s more of a festive tradition
for good food and company than a superstitious
one.
If you happen to recognize the voices of any
of the mummers, then they must immediately
take off their mask.
Mummers usually alter their voices and mannerisms
to avoid being recognized when mumming, sometimes
adopting peculiar and eccentric personas.
In the end, there’s a lot of joyful singing,
eating and dancing, which adds to the local
festive spirit, which is always nice around
Christmas.
Latvia isn’t the only country where a Christmas
tradition has developed that results in food
and drink for the performers.
Something similar, but with a wackier twist,
takes place across villages in southern Wales.
Mari Lwyd is a local folk custom that takes
place on Christmas.
The actual meaning behind “Mari Lwyd”
is disputed to this day.
Some people think it means “Grey Mare,”
referring to the horse head, as well as “lwyd”
being a common term for grey.
Others believe it translates to “Holy Mary,”
a key figure in Welsh Catholicism.
Whatever it means, it’s definitely recognizable
when it comes to your village.
Groups of men and women, often dressed in
flamboyant costumes such as Punch and Judy,
would carry the Mari Lwyd, which is a horse’s
skull on top of a stick, dressed in a frock,
through towns - whilst playing music.
They would travel from house to house and
when they got to your door, they would break
out in song, asking to be invited inside.
It’s customary to sing back and if you choose
to, deny entry with an excuse.
This would go back and forth until either
the troop gives up, leaving and going to the
next house, or the homeowner runs out of excuses,
and is obliged to let them in.
Once inside, the troop puts on a performance,
with the Mari Lwyd chasing around adults and
children alike, snapping its jaws with the
leader pretending helplessly to subdue it.
Mari Lwyd isn’t the only troublemaker in
the troop either, as Punch will even use his
poker to rake out the fire if the homeowner
didn’t forbid him, before they entered the
house.
Food and drinks would be served to the troop
as thanks for their performance and in return
for their blessing.
The earliest records of this bizarre tradition
come from the 19th century, but the actual
origins aren’t clear.
Many think the Mari Lwyd is an offshoot from
pre-Christian, pagan rituals, involving other
hooded animals.
Either way, it’s definitely meant as a goodwill
sentiment, but at the same time, it’s certainly
one of the stranger Christmas traditions out
there.
Nothing says merry Christmas like a horse’s
skull.
Christmas in Venezuela is a particularly important
time of the year in the heavily catholic country.
But in the capital of Caracas, they take it
to a whole new and…exciting level for the
pious morning journey to mass.
Something which has seemingly developed out
of nowhere, is the tradition of roller-skating
to church during the weeks leading up to Christmas.
From the 16th to 24th December, most roads
are closed until 8am to allow the skaters
to get to mass safely.
During this time, you will see streets full
of people skating by with their families.
Because the children usually go to bed early
for the morning mass, they have devised a
cunning way to get up on time.
Some children tie string around their big
toe and dangle it from their bedroom window.
Roller-skaters passing by will tug on the
string to wake the children up.
Personally, I prefer using an alarm clock
to get up in the morning, but I guess getting
pulled out of bed by your big toe is also
viable option, if you’re a particularly
heavy sleeper!
Remember that time you beat a log with a stick
while singing a song, to make it poop out
a shiny new bicycle?
No?
Well that’s what children all over Catalonia
will be doing this Christmas.
It sounds bizarre, but it’s actually an
extremely common tradition that has a big
following in the Catalonian community.
It’s centred on decorating and looking after
Tio de Nadal, “The Christmas Log.”
The log is actually pretty adorable when fully
decorated, with a painted face, a hat and
a blanket, with some versions having little
legs that prop it up.
Leading up to Christmas, it’s customary
to give “Tio” a little bit of food to
eat and cover him with a blanket to keep him
comfortable and warm.
The better looked-after Tio is, the better
the presents he is supposed to provide, I
say “provide” but I actually mean crap
out.
Each family has a slightly different version
of the tradition, but generally, on Christmas
day they put Tio halfway into the fire and
beat it with sticks to make it “defecate”
presents.
No, really.
There are actually very popular songs that
are also sung during the log-beating, gift-defecation
ceremony.
Parents usually send the kids out and ask
them to pray for good gifts while they beat
the log, as a nifty way to sneak presents
under Tio’s blanket whilst they’re not
looking.
Even though the way Tio is supposed to produce
the presents is a little…odd, it’s still
easy to see the charm of the little wooden
fellow.
The lyrics to the songs are also pretty interesting
to say the least.
You probably decorate your Christmas tree
with lights, tinsel and baubles, but in Ukraine
you might find something pretty unexpected
draped around the tree.
It’s common for people there to decorate
their trees with fake webs and even ornamental
spiders.
It might seem like they are a few months late
to Halloween, but there’s actually a reason
for the creepy-crawly shenanigans.
The story goes that a poor, but hardworking
widow lived in a small hut with her children.
One fateful day, a pine cone fell to the earthen
floor and took root, invigorating the children
with the chance of having a Christmas tree
by winter.
The children took care of the tree, helping
it grow, but by the time Christmas came around,
the poor family didn’t have the money to
decorate it, so they went to bed on Christmas
Eve with heavy hearts.
When they woke up on Christmas day, they were
surprised to find the tree was covered in
spider’s webs, and as they opened the windows
to get a better look, the sunlight hit the
webs, turning them to silver and gold.
Needless to say, the family never lived in
poverty again, or at least… that’s how
the folk-tale goes.
This legend is widely believed as the origin
of putting tinsel on Christmas trees, representing
the gold and silver of the transformed spider’s
webs.
It’s amazing to see just how many different
ways people celebrate Christmas, all over
the world.
Some may be stranger than others, but all
of them are based on the same, universal Christmas
spirit.
Thanks for the view and merry Christmas.